si nous n'avions pas été attaquée depuis
le territoire biélorusse nous aurions pu
discuter à minsk votre capital
d'autres villes peuvent être une
plateforme pour une rencontre bien sûr
nous voulons la paix nous voulons nous
rencontrer et mettre fin à la guerre et
varsovie bratislava budapest istanbul
bakou nous avons proposé toutes ces
villes comme lieu de pourparlers et nous
accepterons toute autre ville d'un pays
qui n'a pas été utilisé pour lancer des
missiles
ce n'est qu'alors que les pourparlers
pourront être honnête et mettre fin à la
guerre la biélorussie où se tient par
ailleurs un référendum sur un projet de
constitution ce dimanche ils visent à
renoncer au statut de neutralité et
d'état non nucléaires du pays
le régime d'alexandre loukachenko réélu
frauduleusement en août il y a deux ans
veut renforcer son pouvoir il a pu
rester en place grâce à vladimir poutine
dont il est désormais l'obligé bruno
daroux merci d'être avec nous la vie en
russie c'est un exemple de ce que
souhaitent vladimir poutine a à sa
périphérie
oui absolument spécialement attractif
absolument parce que en fait les les
oppositions qui se sont élevées en
biélorussie contre les conditions de
l'élection de monsieur l'occassion que
vous avez rappelé à l'instant en fait on
fait que la biélorussie est revenu
complètement dans le giron russe a coupé
un peu ses liens avec l'europe de
l'ouest et ça arrange parfaitement
vladimir poutine désormais lukashenko
s'il veut rester au pouvoir il est
coincé et il est obligé d'être avec le
grand frère russe et le référendum de ce
dimanche va permettre en fait comme si
l'abeille et qui est qu une formalité
qui va certainement
être réussie
et visiter voilà plébiscité et en fait
ça va permettre que si on comprend bien
mais je sais pas si la biélorussie pour
le faire tout seul que la biélorussie
sort de son statut d'état non nucléaires
ça pourrait permettre ensuite à moscou
d'installer d'installer peut-être des
armes nucléaires en biélorussie par un
partenariat renforcé entre les deux
états donc on voit bien que la
biélorussie est devenu un état
totalement satellisé à la botte de
moscou et c'est exactement ce que
voudrait faire vladimir poutine
l'expliquera avec l'ukraine parce que
lui on dit souvent qu'il veut
reconstituer le rsa ne veut pas
reconstituer l'urss ils verront si tu es
vraiment ce qu'on appelait l'enfant
serre que la russie telle qu'on la
connaît en dehors de la ville de russie
et de l'ukraine actuellement oui c'est
un immense territoire mais le territoire
utile est beaucoup plus réduit mais si
on y ajoute la biélorussie et l'ukraine
la sarre de via un espace utile est ce
qu'on appelle un territoire utile avec
beaucoup de deux populations qui parlent
le russe et s'adonne à la russie à
supplément de puissance en fait c'est ça
que recherche de manière ultime vladimir
poutine effectivement avec la
biélorussie on peut dire que c'est
quasiment déjà fait et pour le coup sans
coup férir sait rien n'a pas eu besoin
d'intervenir pour revenir à au combat ce
qui se passe actuellement dans la
capitale est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
échec militaire là en ce moment sur kiev
la capitale alors échec militaire ce
serait quand même trop ce qui est sûr
c'est que ça ne se passe pas comme
travis avait été prévu et organisé
vladimir poutine d'ailleurs à changer
son chef d'état major
apparemment il était à ces enragés de
voir quelque chose n'allait pas aussi
facilement que c'était planifié alors je
sais pas si on peut avoir la carte à
l'écran des mouvements des troupes
russes mais disons que face à ce qui se
passe à kiev c'est à dire face à une
résistance ukrainienne qui est plus
importante que prévu résistance de
l'armée résistance de la population
notamment aussi grâce au rôle que joue
le président zelensky qui arrive à
galvaniser son peuple puisque lui tient
le coup et puis les modern dance qui
n'arrête pas de communiquer sur les
réseaux sociaux twitter facebook etc et
donc c'est un jeune président moderne
qui dit à son pays ne baissait pas les
bras
nous allons résister donc il ya une
résistance aussi de la population civile
et ça c'est en train de on le voit dans
tous les reportages de se propager dans
tout le pays en hausse on va peut-être
on est peut-être en train d'assister à
une forme de résurrection patriotique de
l'ukraine et de ce point de vue vladimir
poutine au lieu de de récupérer
l'ukraine sous la tutelle russe il est
en train de faire exploser le sentiment
national ukrainien donc c'est pour ça
que ça n'a pas marché aussi vite qu'il
l'espérait et du coup vladimir poutine
sans doute un peu furieux a ordonné à
ses généraux d'intensifier la prise en
tenaille de l'ukraine on parle nord via
kiev par le sud via la grille mail et
par le nord-est via pour aller sur
kharkiv c'est ce qui est en train de
gérer le témoignage que vous aviez
artificiers moins dit il plus facile à
prendre par exemple c'est ça je ne sais
pas parce que je ne prononcerai pas mais
c'est sans doute une ville jamais allés
nous permettre casser le moral oui ça
lui permettait à six mois et ça lui
permet aussi peut-être de prendre la
ville la plus importante de l'est du
pays il ya un autre élément très
important c'est que c'est pour ça aussi
qu'au sud il ya des batailles
aujourd'hui autour de carson qui est
authier au tout tout à fait au sud à
l'embouchure du fleuve dniepr et le
nieppe en fête à partir de personnes il
remonte jusqu à kiev et c'est presque
une délimitation naturel entre l'est et
l'ouest et donc en visant kharkiv
peut-être le meilleur pour 18 ans parce
qu'on peut dire
je récupère le dombass et le reste de
l'est de l'ukraine voilà on le voit la
sueur bien sûr la carte et c'est
peut-être ce qui est ce qui est en train
de de se jouer en ce moment merci
beaucoup bruno daroux pour votre analyse
merci d'avoir été avec nous les oxydants